I'm not doing 70 substitute teacher
cosplay for no reason it's
back-to-school season how many but
you're something you don't know now you
know you're like it's different now you
guys are back in school or going back to
school or not in school either way
clothes or something we wear and I
remember when I went back to school one
of the biggest stressors was figuring
out what to wear
because what you wear is the quickest
and oftentimes fakest way to let someone
know what you're about without having to
talk clothes help you live thank you so
I thought I'd put together for you for
back to school
look inspiration outfits they're each a
little different maybe they inspire you
for whatever your style might be or
whatever lie you want to tell about
yourself this school year so here's my
five back to school outfit ideas
[Music]
I should no one do this one hey aunt I
wanna do this one what because I just
remember these an actual boyfriend
ex-boyfriend can wait
then my ex-boyfriends pants I don't want
to it just just weird buddy have your
ex-boyfriends appear he never came back
[Music]
[Music]
I don't I want to do this one wait why
not this my mom got fired last year
what she is a professional it's just bad
at it he died what he died he's dyslexic
doesn't everything you do you're not a
doctor
[Music]
I don't wanna do this my grandmother
died in this and I forgot she died in
that shirt she got at me at a kiosk in
the mall it's my dad your dad's gene
Simmons know why this was helpful in you
creating a false image of yourself for
the rest of the school year I wish you
the best of luck on maintaining alive
it's difficult but if you can do it it's
not very fulfilling either way good luck
if you like these kind of videos give
this video a thumbs up so I know cuz I
like making fashion videos and I don't
know if you like them so if you like
them give this video a thumbs up or just
tell me in the comments leave a comment
down below and make sure you subscribe
to this YouTube channel click that ring
bail notification because I try to
upload Monday Wednesday and Friday
doesn't happen frequently but that bail
will tell you when it does happen Saved
by the Bell
Oh school that's appropriate I don't
know Oh also you can give them up at a
cute Airbnb background in Australia but
you can't get the Muppet to stop making
tripods out of whatever's around